there are countless Chinatown's all over
the world in new york boasts one of the
most famous will achieve produce fish
markets and of course a plethora of
Chinese food but if you hop on the one
train take it to the Upper West Side
you'll find a Chinese restaurant like no
other where half the menu is something
else
jalisa CJ Roland's ropa vieja toast on
it
arroz y frijoles this is la caridad 78th
New York's last Cuban Chinese restaurant
comida China is grill oh yeah three oh
yeah how did this unlikely culinary duo
come to be it's a great question
enter Sam Lee sure my wife remember
father came over here or he started I
like his own restaurant
would you like to pin spices and also
the Chinese put mixed together hundreds
of thousands of Chinese came to Cuba in
the 19th and early 20th century
establishing a strong presence on the
island but when Castro came to power
most Chinese immigrants like Sam's
father left many of them coming to the
US and thus Cuban Chinese food was born
I would say la garita restaurant is not
restaurant it's a kitchen for Upper West
siders we have oxtail robbery ha which
is like a strategy at the same time we
search items food is a cook from
Murrieta mainly from China and didn't
learn the train when they got here and
it become very good so are there any
Cuban born workers left I still have a
one filburn worker watcher for me again
I see enemy Kamino Miyagi my name is
Antonia Wong I work in a career I'm a
stallion 1986 I'm gonna hammer knock you
were in 1951
anyway our last key one working regret
oh well Cuban Chinese culture is fading
la caridad is a snapshot of a strange
moment in time where two vastly
different cultures merged together the
Cuban
Chinese people getting older and they
don't have any younger people to go over
I myself felt like I owe my father who
started this restaurant so I wanted to
try to make sure that I carry on the
tradition for TGI Fridays the restaurant
synonymous with classic American staples
like mozzarella sticks and loaded potato
skins a dining Oasis in suburbia but
what if the original concept of TGI
Fridays had nothing to do with that
center Alan Dillman my name is Alan
Dillon that I founded TGI Fridays in
1965 TGI Fridays started not as a
restaurant but a place to mingle the
concept came about from our being about
28 years old and looking for place to
meet his many good-looking woman it's
like good it was New York City and the
year was 1955 TGI Fridays came onto the
scene as one of the world's first
singles bars because back then it wasn't
easy for singles to meet the technique
as a charge was that during the week
people are they phone calls when you
would organize a group of people and you
will end up the different cocktail
parties which basically is what TGI
Fridays was missed
be a cocktail party bikini lubrication
to whether it was a sound plan or not
TGI Fridays blew up almost instantly
attracting more singles from the
neighborhood than anyone could have ever
imagined I was there one evening tending
bar and one of the waiters came up to me
and said listen this half-a-dozen people
outside that want to come in what do we
do I walked out from behind the bar by a
half-hour later and then what 20 people
sitting out there so we may have created
the first wine in the history of the
restaurant business town came into this
with no hospitality experience at all I
would say left him none I added a very
inventive job of reselling perfumes at
flavors Allen became so popular that Tom
Cruise's character from the movie
cocktail was loosely based on him his
character sort of was imitating what we
had done at Friday's at the tub
he was trained with flipping bottles and
drinks much better than I was and when
he looks back Allen's proud of what he
created it was certainly as fun as
anything that you can possibly imagine
it was really something that was quite
special
[Music]
Hey
[Applause]
mi nombre s-- Alejandro Olmedo su Canton
del año para el condado incessant a
quarter pies por todo el mundo que le
monde torah ego Oh damnit a chicken yo
Rita Sarah over r sy a0 la gente disk is
absurd Oh tant ro / a quien es que tal
pero es increible porque la gente le
gusta
[Music]
SoDo los lunas Akina san remo restaurant
a cantamos a las siete de la noche opera
invitamos mo siempre cantante in en el
Sopranos Valley tono's 10 horas y hace
mizuna Buena Fiesta aqui y la pasamos
mara-vee-oso
antes de estar king a restaurant a
estaba en rusia cantando por varios años
can take in en toes Cuarenta siete
concierge for Tohru SIA como en siento
cincuenta ciudades empezar can't Archie
porque esto yo estaba Cena sir nada de
pronto yeah no cream concierto de choses
double holidays a Sega mom in Omaha
faster to say hi after Zdeno Chara voice
amigo Alejandro no entre en su be a
zombie on Teletoon eons our amigo a
chingoo Rostow Hasina's Hamada konami on
Ron Gelardi go sue and raha Mentos
pasinetta inamura Chavo follow sting of
the hello gran gran y dengue hockey Sega
me hermano toreano Toralei me mejor
amigo numero uno nice toy - tempo we
have aikido's funny Celgene de que yo
Tenga este privilegio de cantar e vivvy
vivvy r de l'opéra de mi Tonto
Alessandra Rondo's men have a name is
una mujer de fondo de are so domain
Honda verno door aha go Toto do yo know
canto en un gran Pietro canto compassion
con la verdad con todo mi corazón y
cuando canto resaurant a igual uno de
donde sia yo tengo que contar
total unfolded on the surface the
Ganesha temple in Queen seems like just
a place of worship for Hindus but if you
take the side entrance down the hall
with all the lights follow the signs
down the stairs follow more sign down
more stairs you'll find the temple
canteen a restaurant serving food to
rival anything you would find in India
[Music]
this is dr. uma Mysore car
namaste I'm the president of the Hindu
temple Society of North America in
Flushing New York the temple came into
existence in 1977 and as one of the
first of its kind in North America the
temple has become a cultural hub for
Hindus throughout the u.s. this is a
place like home people who come to the
temple spend their whole day here they
have their worshipping services in the
morning and then very often we have
cultural programs but also they come
here to eat they come to the temple to
eat yes they do come here to eat some of
them come just only to eat not even to
come inside the temple so in addition to
a place of worship a community center
and a wedding venue the Ganesha temple
serves cuisine authentic to South India
and is open to the public and the food
is pretty fantastic
just as the New York time for New York
magazine or Anthony Bourdain
it's not easy to find our Indian food
everywhere around the corners so people
come to find authentic Indian food okay
so if you don't know anything about that
Indian food here are some of the
must-haves Sara's Vera I always called
it as a salty doughnut Italy it is
nothing but puffed rice sambar it is
made of lentils ready healthy and most
notably dosas there are at least about
eight or nine kinds of doses it consists
of down and there is a
filling inside we have an authentic
Indian cook in our Hinduism we strongly
believe we thought the offering of food
to the deities our prayer is incomplete
and that's how it really started but I
think when you go to a canteen or a
restaurant you want to enjoy your food
we want to make sure that whether it is
a Hindu or a non symbol should be able
to enjoy the food
who cares really whether it is an Indian
restaurant or a non Indian restaurant
you just want to go and eat so the next
time you're hungry and Queen try the
temple
[Music]